there's no Trump ignored multiple
warnings from the Obama administration
about his name fired national security
advisor for the first time former acting
Attorney General Sally Yates testified
how she told the White House that Russia
could blackmail retired General Michael
Flynn that followed the news that former
President Obama personally warned the
president he should not hire Flynn
president Trump did not address the
substance of Yates charges instead
writing on Twitter that Yates quote said
nothing but old news and he repeated
that alleged collusion between his
campaign and Russia are a total hoax
Jeff Pegues covered yesterday's hearing
pretty revealing he's with us now in
studio 57 Jeff good morning good morning
it was another riveting day of testimony
on Capitol Hill under questioning from
senators the former acting attorney
general a key figure in the
investigation into Russian interference
in the 2016 election described the
urgency she felt to warn the White House
that former national security adviser
Michael Flynn was compromised to state
the obvious you don't want your national
security adviser compromised with the
Russians Sally Yates says she had two
separate meetings and a phone call with
white House Counsel Don Magan about
Michael Flynn's conversation with the
Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac we
were giving them all of this information
so that they could take action
investigators had intercepts of the
contacts and Yates says it was clear to
her that Flynn had misled the vice
president leaving Flynn vulnerable to
blackmail the Russians also knew about
what general Flynn had done that created
a compromised situation a situation
where the national security adviser
essentially could be blackmailed by the
Russians but despite her warnings in
late January the White House waited more
than two weeks to fire Flynn mr. McCain
asked me whether or not general Flynn
should be fired and I told him that that
really wasn't our call Republicans on
the committee expressed concern to Yates
and James clapper the former Director of
National Intelligence under President
Obama that private data about Trump
campaign officials was swept up in
foreign surveillance did either
you ever requests the unmasking of mr.
Trump his associates or any member of
Congress yes in one case I did
clapper admitted he asked to unmask or
reveal the identities of campaign
associates and classified documents but
insisted Trump's team was not the target
my focus was on the foreign target and
at the foreign targets behavior in
relation to the u.s. person subcommittee
chairman Lindsey Graham left with
unanswered questions I want to know who
who was surveilled in this country as a
presidential campaign I want to know how
incidental surveillance works I want to
know who unmasked if there was an
unmasking of general Flynn Graham also
praised he Eights for her actions but
she was fired by the White House when
she refused to defend the president's
travel ban that was four days after she
had warned them about general Flynn Gail
thank you Jeff